welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about the
mysterious creature with the head of an
alligator hiding in the darkened corners
of your mind what's that creature you
want me to steal the declaration of
independence huh maybe my name is mt and
i'm here today with off-screen producer
brandon what's going on brandon hello mt
so glad to have you back i'm i'm just so
excited to have this new show to talk
about i can't even believe moon knight
season is finally here i haven't been
clamoring for moon night for so long and
we finally have it spring has sprung and
moon knight has wrapped himself in the
the colors of easter and is ready to to
bring a new season of marvel upon us
it's moonlight savings baby
hey
but what's up big question today brandon
well mt we've got the first episode of
moon night fresh on our peepers and now
that we know one of ethan hawk's
character aka arthur harrow's fetishes
is walking around with glass in his
shoes oh we want to know more about this
deity that he's doing all this for so it
all leads us to this week's big question
who is ahmed and why is she such a
threat to the mcu yo that is a great
question but first of all back to those
uh the sandals moment that was probably
the most gruesome opening to any marvel
or anything that i've ever seen in my
days like i like my feet were never the
same after that that's like how do you
think
how do you not start out that show with
the song walk it on broken glass what's
arthur harrow's like drinking glass
budget is he going through a glass a day
that's excessive they don't let them
stay at hotels they're like no no you
can't you can't stay here you keep
breaking over
you're leaving the room come on this is
why we get plastic cups at hotels now
because uh arthur harold's been breaking
all the glasses but ahmet like many of
the mystical beings on the show has ties
to both the comics and real world
egyptian mythology because in egyptian
mythology ahmed was known as the
devourer of the dead and was often
represented by having the body of a lion
and hippopotamus with the head of a
crocodile and she was a goddess that
would you know eat the hearts of those
deemed unworthy by anubis which is kind
of hardcore hardcore
and thus unable to enter the underworld
your worthiness was judged by the weight
of your heart against a feather of moth
and mat was the concept of truth harmony
balance and order in the ancient egypt
if ahmet ate your heart then your soul
would never be fully passed on to the
underworld and your spirit was doomed to
wander around aimlessly for all of
eternity so not a great way to spend
your your dead years wow you want to be
nice you want to be in the nice
underworld like relaxing having a
cocktail exactly you want to be
wandering around
soulless no place to be just want to go
retire to the i don't know the florida
of the underworld you don't want to be
eaten by ahmed it's just it's not a good
luck exactly good luck so that's what we
know about ahmet from her place in
egyptian mythology but what about her
place in the marvel comics and what
might that tell us about her purpose in
the moon night show because in the
comics ahmed plays a very similar role
she was created by one of earth's elder
gods ashter and austria is also known as
the goddess mat thus making the link
from the comics to real world mythology
and ahmed is a sphynx which
traditionally is a creature with the
head of a human the body of a lion and
the wings of a falcon and in ahmed's
case she represents herself with the
head of a crocodile and the body that is
a mix of a lion a leopard and a
hippopotamus like the movie madagascar
another thing that sphinx are known for
is asking riddles something that ahmed
is known to do in the comics and she is
a very powerful and magical creature
that can control and resist the magic of
other beings so along with consuming the
hearts and souls of people she can also
consume the minds and absorb the
knowledge of her victims which is which
would have come in real handy in college
let me tell you that um i mean not that
you know
i wouldn't kill people for the knowledge
but you'd be willing to eat the smart
kid in class just to get get back
exactly because it's usually the snob
he's like i know everything yeah i'll
eat him first
bite-sized brains
she's also able to change her form from
that of a crocodile-headed creature to
that of a human something that we could
potentially see in this series her being
able to turn into a human in the comics
is something we could see because
there's this weird thing with a lot of
the aeneid and ian however you want to
say it where like they can't necessarily
come to earth directly right
like we were talking about this on an
earlier big question with ra
he can never come into the earthly realm
because he's like too powerful or too
mystical or something so he always has
to have an avatar but because ahmed it's
not necessarily one of the aeneid or the
anyad
maybe she's able to actually form
herself on earth and not have to use an
avatar though she probably will it seems
to be something they like using with
these egyptian gods i'm really
interested to see what they do with the
whole avatar concept because like it
seems like yeah like you said like a
human host is necessary right for these
gods
to be amongst us i wonder what the mcu
justification for that's going to be
because if you're a powerful god what's
going to keep you from going on earth
because we saw odin showing on earth
right at some point like well and this
could be a thing maybe the egyptian gods
they got like the short end of the stick
from the elder gods and they're like
what the hell you let the asgardians
come down all the time why can't we come
down we got to use these avatars and
like that's probably why khan shu is so
angry right he's so frustrated he has to
rely on these champions to do his
bidding when he's like i just want to
come down to earth use my crow head and
peck out the eyes of every mother that
steps to me but instead i gotta deal
with these guys and you know sometimes
they have problems that i got to deal
with their issues and then you know they
got to go to work and they don't want to
do what i ask them to do and it's
frustrating steve do you not know how
lucky you are to be able to kill people
on earth in that first episode there's
like nothing that he's to like this guy
he's just like oh get this idiot out of
here come on
it's like all right he calls him a
parasite i'm like yeah yeah why does he
call steve a parasite that's so mean
it's actually crushing to here but one
thing that ahmed is known to do in the
comics in between you know eating all
those unworthy hearts is guard the halls
of mott which contain the throne of bone
it's what they call my bed you know what
i'm talking about the old thing the
throat of buddha
that's so good i'm gonna actually you
can you can use it you can i'll give you
that i'm gonna use that for the future
welcome to the throne of bone and the
sword of bone and the sword of bone is a
powerful mystical weapon that can only
be wielded by those deemed worthy kind
of like you know something else that we
know but we you know we won't talk about
this so many items in the mcu or marvel
comics that like you have to be worthy
to wield i mean come on guys seriously
so if you try to use the sword and
you're not worthy it often won't reveal
its true powers and in some cases may
just turn into a normal rib bone yeah
and some of the comics like they go to
grab it because it's like part of a
skeleton and they grab it and it just
like tur it turns into a sword but then
like turns back into a rib and they're
like oh well i guess
this isn't useful at all i think that's
a fun idea for the sword it's like hey
if you don't if you don't use it right
it's going to turn into a regular bone
depending on what bone it is you can
still kill somebody with them it's a rip
bone so it's a little sharp you know you
could you could yeah you could do some
damage you could kill somebody with
choke something i mean
probably not the best thing to bring to
a war
no
no probably not but yeah the sword of
bone is one of the cornerstones of
creation along with the dark hold the
ebbing rose and the serpent crown and
supposedly if you wield all four of the
cornerstones of creation you could
control all of reality you know kind of
like the infinity stones
and while guarding the sort of bone
ahmed would come face to face with the
mutant magic the corrupted egyptian
sorcerer hecka nut echonut coconut
[Laughter]
welcome to the throne of bone where
everyone gets a heck of a net
dangerous dangerous so the corrupted
egyptian sorcerer hecka newt manipulated
the mutant magic to travel through time
back to the 11th century bc in order to
obtain the powerful sword of bone and
ahmad actually helps magic get the sword
for hecka newt knowing that he would not
be worthy enough to wield it and that
would be his downfall and the same sort
of bone was also attempted to be
obtained by the magic wielder ian mcnee
oh it's me
ian mcnee the magicky boy such a cute
little name he's a cool looking dude
he's got like the nice round glasses he
looks like a hippie he's a cool guy he
wanted to be the source of supreme so he
learned a bunch of magic and then he
challenged doctor strange uh and he lost
no surprise there i wanna uh what if
with
what if doctor mcneek what if it were me
he would make me to lead you three
you graduated summa [ __ ] laude i
graduated magna [ __ ] laude just behind
you stephen strange but one day ian
mcknee shall rise to power he was on a
quest himself to obtain the four
cornerstones of creation and he thought
he was doing it at the behest of oster
herself but it turns out that it was
actually catholic disguised as oster
trying to get ian to bring him all the
four cornerstones but ian caught wise to
the plan in time and used the
cornerstones to banish cathon to the
flickering realms that's got to be an
annoying place because you're trying to
read and like the lights are just
flickering all the time you're like this
is annoying this is so annoying all this
all this stuff is like very interesting
mt like the idea of the cornerstones of
creation because we have the darkhold in
the mcu now i don't know if they're
gonna get into like the sword of bone on
like moon night that seems like a little
crazy but you know they've just
introduced like the ebony blade another
powerful sword and it's like you know
you have the dweller in darkness which
we saw in chongqi you know the rings are
reaching out to something out there that
we don't know what it is we were talking
earlier about how these egyptian gods
they need to use avatars or they speak
to the minds of of humans here on earth
and that's something that the dweller in
darkness was doing right it was speaking
to when woo
it did it couldn't come into our
dimension because it was blocked off by
the wall or the doorway but like maybe
that's maybe that's the connection here
where like for whatever real reason
these aeneid were banished as well and
they're trying to find ways to like get
back into our realm maybe through
powerful magical objects that exist here
in our realm i think that that you're
that is spot on what the entire
plan is with this darker phase of the
mcu moving forward because we are seeing
like you said the the ebony blade was
introduced at the end of eternals we
have the ten rings which um seem to be
linked to this a dark realm or dark
beings like the dweller in darkness and
we have the dark hold which seems to be
linked to
some other dark entities in the mcu so
like it seems that this is very much
some type of plan we don't have a
confirmation of the midnight suns coming
to the mcu quite yet but you know oscar
isaac just brought it up in passing in
an interview um and like it just feels
like this is with with blade being
introduced and like you know the
werewolf by night yeah these dark
objects we're gonna see more and more
doc objects being introduced into the
mcu slowly with another adopt object
being the symbiote uh spider-man
symbiote that we'll definitely be seeing
inspired by before so yeah i think that
maybe we could see these cornerstones
pop up in the mcu and maybe in a
different way maybe not the sort of bone
but like maybe it'll be like you know
the the ten rings will be one of those
cornerstones yeah and the dark hole to
be a cornerstone so i would love to see
that for sure yeah it does feel like the
first three phases of the mcu were you
know like science will save us right
tony stark and all the science he's
inventing uh right you know the science
to make captain america the the serums
all that stuff creating vision like yes
there were like the infinity stones
which were mystical but it was all about
how science is going to save us we're
using science to travel through time all
that stuff right now it's like science
can no longer save you because there's
multiverses there's celestials there's
all these things that your your pitiful
human science can't stop
so it's going to be all about like these
mystical items and this dark magic and
how do we right the darkness that lives
inside of us before it was all about
like the science approach to energy in
the mcu and now we're going to the magic
approach to energy at the mcu and that's
just i don't know more fun because now
we get to see more crazy things like
moonlight
but yeah surprisingly ahmed hasn't shown
up too much in the moon night comics in
one time conscious sent mark spector to
a fake mental hospital one that just
existed as an illusion but in an effort
to fully break down mark's mind and it
was in this illusion that ahmed
possessed a psychiatrist known as dr
emmett and in this instance kanchu and
ahmed were working together so that's a
little look at what we know about ahmed
from the comics but what makes her so
threatening in the moonlight program
because it looks like we have a main
villain in arthur harrow who isn't a
heavy hitter in the comics doing all
this work on behalf of amit who again
isn't a big time goddess like she's not
one of the aeneid so is she a big threat
to our world here
that's a great question mt i mean it's
tough to say it does seem like in that
first episode they
we even have
uh stephen slash mark spectre but it was
stephen at the time pointing out like oh
this poster of the emmy ed or aenead or
however you want to say it right that
seems to be a big focus here but
uh
alma is not one of those right she's not
one of the the top nine in fact she
works under them she works under anubis
now we did have that like weird jackal
creature in the first episode
that moon knight has to put the beat
down on but i don't think that's anubis
right that's just like a demon dog or
something right it's one that's just
like a you know yeah so maybe like ahmet
is using arthur harrow and they're all
working together for anubis right i feel
like anubis is at the top of this this
whole food chain uh
on a previous big question i did with
jessica we were talking about how in the
comics anubis has this whole scheme to
like steal ra's heart to grain ross
power to take over the enid they hide
away uh raw's heart in africa and that's
what becomes the heart-shaped or herb
and all that stuff i'm wondering if this
is a similar situation here where like
anubis for whatever reason wants to get
into our realm and can't do it so he
needs like ahmed to help but maybe ahmed
needs to power up by getting some more
hearts maybe because people don't
believe in egyptian mythology anymore
the gods are less powerful i don't know
it doesn't seem to affect the asgardians
right very few people believe in norse
mythology but their power still works
here on earth but maybe for some reason
like egyptian the egyptian gods they
need people to believe in them in order
to have more power i don't know what do
you think interesting no i really like
the idea of like you're spread up of
like the
the gods potentially like using harrow
were you saying like sucking like
sucking the energy like yeah yeah like
they use because right we saw how arthur
harrow's able to like use his little his
cane scale which is so yeah why would
you go let him do that i'm not going to
trust some guy to just tell me that his
tattoo says i'm good man that old lady
looks like she was up to no good i know
no good he dropped that old [ __ ]
yeah where was captain marvel when we
needed to be like
what happened yeah why does the mcu hate
old people oh beer they gotta go
it does seem like strange like
he has this power to like
allow people to die and i guess he's
saying it's like emma working through
him but is it i still think he might
actually be
uh anubis like in disguise or something
or like an avatar of a newborn but i i
feel like is that is is the power
getting transferred through arthur
harrow into america i honestly think
that once you brought that up i was like
oh my god this reminds me a lot of shang
qi i know like this is exactly what
those like little squid guys were doing
again
sucking all the souls for people to feed
to the dweller in darkness and like
that's a really good idea like that
could exactly be what's happening here
ahmet is collecting souls to you know
maybe just power up for some some grand
purpose because they're they're not as
strong as they used to be yeah all these
creatures from the dark dimension is
like you guys are over here fighting
about oil and stuff that's that's
useless forget your oil it's souls baby
you got to be drilling for souls
drill baby drill
[Laughter]
hey capitalism sucks soul sucks souls
all the time tell me about it brother
and while you're here support us at new
rock city
get ready for the ad that's coming up
shortly we love capitalism here at new
rockstars it's great we're a big fan of
it hooray yeah i i definitely could see
i'm i'm like slowly playing arrow and
like saying like oh yeah harrow you're
on this huge like really great justified
journey to make heaven on earth but like
you're actually just uh feeding me with
all the good souls that i need do you
think ahmed's like the ultimate big bad
here do you think there's someone
pulling her strings to get arthur
herrera to do his stuff i think that
this could be a case of somebody
impersonating as ahmed i think that we
could be looking as because there's also
the egyptian god sobek who also plays a
role in um that uh moon knight series
that you were talking about where um uh
moon knight was in this illusion uh
hospital yeah i feel like sobek is also
this crocodile god that could actually
be just pulling the strings here and i
don't know why i get this vibe but like
i just feel like ahmet is being framed
um here yeah it does seem like actually
the big bad to get it right in the first
episode it does seem like yeah this
can't be like the final stage here right
honestly ahmed is just a tool of anubis
ahmed is there to eat the dead to devour
the dead but like what is the bigger
purpose of of ahmed you know doing these
things collecting these souls there's
something at play here and like it's
definitely links to in my opinion
the dark
realm of the mcu like wherever the
dweller of darkness came from wherever
um you know your dormammus or come from
like the dark dimensions like these dark
beings
it's definitely one of these beings that
is probably just messing with with all
the humans like arthur hero and that one
little clip we've seen in some of the
promo materials of like the egyptian
room that that mark specter like walks
into or maybe stephen i don't know who
he is at that point walks into and
there's that woman with the red dress do
you think that could be ahmed or do you
think maybe that's someone else i think
that that could definitely be her for
sure because like i mean it seems like
we're in some type of chamber of like
you know powerful gods with with the way
that she's dressed she's dressed like
she's standing out for somebody so i
think we could be seeing ahmed here
maybe or at least maybe like our human
avatar right someone speaking on her yes
the human avatar vomit in red all in all
with ahmed like how big do you think
she's gonna actually survive moon knight
and like be a bigger threat moving on to
the mcu i think this story of the aeneid
and ian whatever you want to call it i
think it is gonna wrap up with the moon
night i don't know if it's gonna have
like far-reaching complications for the
mcu the indian's connection to like dark
magic is gonna have like a bigger play
in this like whatever the result i don't
think ahmed survives this series i think
they defeat ahmed for whatever purpose
they need to
but can you really defeat ahmed forever
i don't know if i don't know if you can
kill these egyptian
gods and goddesses like for good good i
don't know if they're dead dead
but i think they're gonna stop her but i
think
it's gonna lead into the darker magic
problems of the mcu and that's gonna
help get moon knight kind of connected
to some of the other
more mystical
entities out there your blades your
black sons your midnight sons your
doctor strangers uh yeah i think i think
that's the danger that's the ultimate
danger that ahmet that's the threat she
poses here is that she is another
conduit for dark magic that can be used
against the the forces of good in the
mcu but before we continue new
rockstarsmerch.com just released our
newest latest obsession shirt the one
inspired by moon knight and it looks
absolutely incredible and these are
limited edition shirts that are not only
cool and collectible but they also
directly support us here at new
rockstars and help us make all of our
content and it really really does help
us a lot so check out the moon knight
latest obsession shirt and other great
moon night merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com please we would
love if you did that before we dive into
our bite size questions next some words
from the people to help bring big
question to you people like mint mobile
because if saving money is on your 2022
agenda why are you still paying insane
amounts of money every month for
wireless switching to mit mobile is the
easiest way to save this year and as the
first company to sell premium wireless
service online only mint mobile lets you
maximize your savings with plans
starting at just 15 a month and we've
got an editor and a host here at new
rockstars that switched to mint mobile
recently and they absolutely love it
like they get to keep their phones and
their numbers and they're saving a ton
of money and by going online only and
eliminating the traditional cost of
retail mint mobile passes significant
savings on to you and all plans come
with unlimited talk and text plus
high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network and with
mint mobile choose the amount of monthly
data that's right for you and stop
paying for data that you just never use
and switch to mid mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month to get your new wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month and get
the plan shipped right to your door for
free go to mittmobile.com bigq that's
mintmobile.com
big q cut your wireless belt to just 15
bucks a month at mintmobile.com
big q in march of this year someone paid
2.4 million dollars for marvel comics
issue number one it wasn't me don't ask
don't come to my house to try and
just like me you probably weren't one of
the top bidders for that comic what if
you could invest in the most valuable
comics and collectibles in the world
even if you don't have a spare million
or two lying around that's where
masterworks comes in the art and
collectibles market is valued at 1.7
trillion dollars that's trillion with a
t oh we got trouble right here in river
city and that market is expected to grow
another 900 billion dollars by 2026.
masterworks is the first platform that
enables you to access this market at
reasonable price points all thanks to
their revolutionary approach where they
purchase items and register them with
the sec so members on their platform can
buy shares of specific items it's
awesome for collectors and it
diversifies your finances having a piece
of a famous comic or a banksy or a war
hall painting is a little more fun than
a random mutual fund masterworks is
giving our listeners special vip access
just go to masterworks.art bigquestion
that's
dot art slash big question see important
regulation a disclosures at masterworks
dot io slash cd
nice well brandon now it is time for our
bite size questions
tasty
does each universe in the multiverse
have their own set of celestials and
this is from senior snook 16 on twitter
thank you senior snook yes well senor
snook that's a yes and a no it's a
little complicated so let's start at the
beginning the very beginning in the
comics when there was just one universe
known as the first firmament oh and
wasn't it beautiful
it's during this time that the
celestials that we know rebelled against
another group of celestials known as the
aspirants that's right those celestials
that we have that we think are just old
boomers telling us what to do they were
actually the cool young rebels at one
point it was during the celestial war
that uh the the first firmament or the
first universe was broken into multiple
universes creating the first multiverse
whoa
it happened
so since the celestials created the
multiverse they get to have special
modding abilities in the multiverse what
that's not fair and therefore they're
present within each multiverse uh but
their presence is not like the
fully-fledged variants that we know we
have a copy of a living being in each
multiverse and they're all different and
they're separate and they're separate
variants right no no no that's not how
celestials work the celestials exist in
each multiverse as an avatar with each
one linked to their main celestial so if
you kill a celestial in your universe
you have not necessarily killed it
completely you just wiped out its avatar
it can respawn again so that sucks
i'm back baby
there have been instances in the comics
of celestials being killed and reborn
such as exeter who's been killed by both
sue storm and thor and he's still around
and he keeps on ticking the fact that
sue storm killed exotar is uh kind of
crazy yeah i mean the fantastic he's not
a celestial that is uh weak at all yeah
they get around and they do some damage
uh guys watch out for those fantastic
four they're dangerous
picture that
but everywhere yeah uh marvel's fantasy
is here to kill baby
[Music]
perfect
empty did you know if you if you kill
all the celestials and only except one
and just one celestial is left alive
that that one celestial can then like
respawn all the other celestials all
over again you got to kill them all if
you want to get them all dead that is
bananas that could mean that the tiama
and the mcu that was killed or prevented
from like you know being being born uh
he's not fully dead right he could just
be reborn again they could just plant
them in another planet and start all
over again like i hope that's true
because like then maybe aeroshim would
be less mad at the eternals for what
they did it's like ah don't worry about
it well he's still gonna be pissed he
does it's not
empty it's not what they did it's the
fact that they talk back to him he
doesn't appreciate that it's true he's
just really disappointed in their
actions it's like guys just kill the
entire human race what's the big deal
this is one there's there's tons of
there's tons of aliens all over the
place getting killed all the time who
cares about the humans who cares right
you know but of course empty we don't
know if this is how it works in the mcu
we assume this is how it works in the
mcu right uh they haven't fully codified
that but i it's probably the same
that like the the celestials we have in
the mcu are just avatars i feel like the
marvel comics can do a lot more crazier
[ __ ] than the mcu which seemed to have a
lot more concrete rules and
realism they got all they got a lot of
comic books are right guys they got a
lot of stories to tell it's true
things are going to get crazy and we
love them all but brandon i got another
bite-sized question for you thank you
for that first one that's a lot of good
knowledge there but
can you answer this one can the flash
from dc comics run in outer space and
this is from alice chern chain on
twitter thank you alice yes yes so
you're asking if you put the speedy
little flash in the vacuum of space how
would he run around if he didn't have
any ground to push off of or like any
gravity exactly he may not be able to
run in space but he could move parts of
his body fast enough to generate thrust
like he could take his little finger and
he could wave it back and forth like
kind of fast enough and create a little
energy and like push himself through
space a little bit yes that's a that's
the key to a good marriage
brandon ah tell me about it
welcome to the throne of bone
whoops
and in the silver age
they would have him move through space
at nearly the speed of light by
basically vibrating the atoms inside of
his body and then like ejecting them
with enough force i mean guys
the speed force is a weird thing that
can do whatever it wants i i love
anything that has to do with the flash
vibrating as atoms to get himself out of
the situation because it's just so
it's like god mode it's like i can do
anything i'm just going to
don't touch me
don't touch me
there's also been like plenty of
instances of the flash or like other
speedsters breaking escape velocity
meaning they generate enough speed to
like leave earth's orbit like i think
there's one type of like kid flash who's
like they're like racing or something
he's like don't go too fast or you won't
you'll reach escape velocity and he's
like what's that and he's like whoops
and he just like starts floating away
and the idea being like you're going so
fast that you can't even stop because
like gravity doesn't work anymore and
like you're just gonna keep going and
going forever so the flash can't like
run in space but he can certainly move
uh he's not you can't stop the flash by
putting him in a vacuum it's not gonna
work thank you brandon for those amazing
answers but now it is time for our box
of scraps
of scraps you should okay with a box of
scraps a box of scraps
brandon or should i say william
scientist william from iron man one box
of scraps uh if you had to work in a
museum what exhibit would you want to be
in charge of oh
oh that's interesting well you know mt i
i would love to be a tour guide in a
museum uh i think that would be like the
most fun poor stevie grant wants to be a
tour guide so bad and he was he's so
good with kids you know let him be a
tour guide i think i would want to be in
charge of like a really cool exhibit
where i could give a tour talking about
like medieval torture devices because i
think that would be like very cool and
dark and scary and you could use a lot
of fun voices uh you could really freak
out the kids by showing them like oh
would you like to be trapped inside of
this iron maiden uh though i have read i
have read a lot of like what we consider
to be medieval torture devices aren't
real like they were made up during like
the victorian era era when like you know
museums were coming to prominence and
they'd be like oh look at this ancient
thing we found where they would put
people on there they just made them up
yeah they would just make [ __ ] up to be
like oh isn't this freaky now don't get
me wrong mt there are plenty of torture
devices that very much existed
throughout uh his human nature
and humans
humans have done a lot of messed up
stuff to each other and you know what we
still keep doing it uh
but sometimes we make up the messed up
stuff we do to each other and that's
even more fun uh so yeah i would be that
that guy at the museum who takes you on
like the dark exhibit but then is also
telling you you know what this is bs
don't don't buy into this this is this
is not true this is a fake this is a
fake game what about you emt i would
probably
be in some type of like space museum
because i love space a lot yeah like i
just love looking at like you know
exploring like galaxies and like
freaking black holes and like the
science of all that so like if i just
had all that knowledge in my brain and
be like hey kids come on over
here's a black hole that could kill you
at any moment
let's come learn about this um it's just
i love that type of stuff i think you're
i think it'd be a good museum docent mt
i would listen i would listen to your
your facts oh man it'd just be me
rambling they'd probably just kick me
out they would they would just assume
that i was the man who just walked in
and like um just decided to start
talking about museum stuff
i actually work there i'm just a weird
person
anyway that is it for this episode of
big question thank you so much to
brandon for joining me on this episode
please follow him grin and barrack on
twitter because he tweets some great
stuff follow me at mastertainment on
twitter to see me tweet some really
weird [ __ ] but most importantly follow
new rockstars here on youtube and all
social media platforms because that
really helps us a lot and make sure you
hit the notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and if you want to continue the
conversation our new rockstars discord
server is now open to the public just
please make sure you are 18 years old
and older but anyways thank you guys so
much again for watching we love you guys
so much and we'll see you guys next time
goodbye bye
[Music]
you